the problem in this video comes from a
1982 SAT exam this math problem was so
hard that no one selected the correct
answer can you figure it out in the
following figure circle a has one-third
the radius of circle B circle a rolls
around circle B one trip back to its
starting point how many times will
Circle a revolve in total the answer
choices are three halves three six nine
halves and nine get out some pencil and
paper and see if you can figure it out
remember this was on the SAT so it's a
timed exam and the students would have
had to figure it out just using pencil
and paper here is what the test
preparers thought when they made the
question if circle a rolls around a
distance of three times its
circumference if you do it very
carefully you'll find that circle a will
roll around three times in total and
that's what they thought the correct
answer should be but let's do a little
experiment and see what actually happens
if we have circle a rolling around
circle B I've made cardboard cutouts of
these circles if circle a starts at the
top and I carefully roll it around
circle B after 1/4 of the distance
circle a has already revolved around one
time when we go half way around circle B
circle a around a second time as we
continue around will see that by 3/4 of
the distance circle a will roll a third
time and when we complete the trip as
circle a rolls around circle B when it
completes the trip this will be a fourth
time that circle a has rolled
round so the correct answer is four and
they actually made a mistake they did
not include this as the correct answer
they forgot to take into account that
circle a is revolving around circle B
and that would have added one more trip
around let's try and solve this problem
in general imagine having two coins of
equal circumference you would think the
answer might be one but you see that
when the coin rolls around halfway it's
already rolled around one time when it
rolls around the remaining distance it
will roll around a second time so we can
solve this problem and we'll see the
correct answer is that circle a will
roll around n plus 1 times the reason is
that circle B has end times the
circumference and that will account for
n times that the circle a revolves
around itself but then we will also get
one more revolution because circle a is
also revolving around the center of
circle B so the correct answer is n plus
1 it's a pretty interesting problem I
hope you liked the video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can also catch me at brushed
all occur on social media and if you
like the video please check out my books
I've provided links in the video
description thanks for watching